Let's talk next to let's go to
Louise from Chicago, Illinois.
Hi, David. Hello.
I'm just wondering,
like I've seen your discussions
with people like Tim Poole and.
Ben.
But just people from the right,
so I'm just wondering if there's going to
be more discussions like that in the future.
Maybe I mean, I don't know. You know, one of the
reasons I've gotten away from doing it is that.
I find that it's extraordinarily unproductive to
engage with just sort of like bad faith actors
in performative debate, like I know, I know it
does well in terms of clicks. And I know it's like
fun and funny, but I, I don't know that I'm
really doing much to sort of like advance
the cause of really thinking deeply about issues
and that type of thing. And there's so often
cancelations, people are so flaky. You know, I
plan my schedule around these things and then
people don't show up. And I don't know. I mean,
I'm always as a general thing, like, yeah, I'm up
to to show up for talking with people, but I just
don't know. I don't know. I guess I'm ambivalent.
OK, thank you. Would you like to see
more of that, I mean, give me your sense.
Yeah, it's kind of fun and it's all right,
but do we learn from it, is the question?
I feel like it kind of encourages you to.
Got them to contradict themselves and,
yeah, kind of exposes them, but I don't
know, but I guess that's what I mean.
Like if Tim comes on, like when Temple came
on and he was like, I'm against any identity
politics. And then he goes as an Asian, I
believe. And then I said, whoa, Tim, hold
on. That's a contradiction. Like, it's funny, we
all laugh, but do we advance our understanding of
any of these issues in any way when it's
funny and contradictory? I don't know.
I don't know. Yeah, I think it's it's
less productive than just setting up.
Dialog with like actual experts. Yeah, right. I
mean, I I guess it kind of gets the conversation
started that maybe that maybe.
Yeah, I'll think about it
more. I appreciate you bringing it up.
OK, thank you. All right, it's a good question.
It is, and, you know, there's really arguments
to be made on both sides about that. I don't
think it's I don't think there's like a clear,
obvious and and right answer one way or the other.